sarde youtubers e benvenuti ad una nuova
recensione prima di iniziarla come al
solito vorrei consigliarvi un canale e
il canale degli italian ner dire più un
gruppo di ragazzi che fa recensioni di
film faccio pubblicità alla concorrenza
sono molto simpatici molto preparati
quindi iscrivetevi perché ne vale la
pena
detto questo iniziamo il film che
decisero oggi è un defilé ball un film
del 1994 diretto da golf o avete
presente e jackie chan e jet li e trony
già dimenticate vili e al loro posto
mettete cinzia il rock rock john miller
e donne miam il film non credo sia mai
arrivato in italia ma online è
abbastanza facile da reperire
quindi vediamo cosa ci propone questo
putridume e tanto sono io quello che se
li deve guardare si film è certo
numero 5 il regista prima di addentrarci
nei finn vero e proprio fermiamoci un
attimo sul regista
goldtrail o non l'avevo mai sentito
nominare ma quando sono andato a
controllare la sua filmografia ho
scoperto che un paio dei suoi film
compreso ande fitball li ho visti i
problemi che è lui a atto oltre 100 film
lasciatemi ripetere oltre 100 film nel
2000 per fortuna si è ritirato dico per
fortuna perché negli altri paesi lui è
considerato le wood cinese io ripeto ho
visto soltanto un paio dei suoi film
però dai titoli degli altri film che non
ho visto posso immaginare il perché lo
chiamassero così guardate ninja i
guerrieri di fuoco ninja avengers ninja
commandments in già del squad lynch
extreme weapon ninja in action vince a
kinigi operation nicea fantoni già
condotto di lascio indovinare qual era
il suo genere preferito
un film di zombie zombie versus ninja
ovviamente ma come se non bastasse c'è
scritto che alcuni dei suoi primi film
non erano veri e propri film in che
senso
grazie per aver chiesto
prendete un film cinese sconosciuto
anche i cinesi stessi fatto bene
ritagliate alcune scene e mettete della
parte prendete un altro film sconosciuto
ritagliate scene da questo e mettete
nella parte ora avete due gruppi di
scene di due film differenti unite lì
insieme con della colla vinilica di
quello che viene fuori doppiate neil
young in modo che la storia abbia un
senso
et voilà mar illegale ovviamente non
tutti i suoi film sono così ho letto che
soltanto i primi sono fatti in questo
modo comunque
4 la recitazione fatevi raccontare in 2d
che la trama c'è un campione di arti
marziali che ad un certo punto
impazzisce per che la moglie lo lascia
allora inizia a uccidere tutte le donne
che assomigliano alla moglie un
detective che sa le arti marziali si
allea con una donna che fa combattimenti
underground per catturare il campione di
arti marziali
tutto qui vedi passiamo alla recitazione
è un film di arti marziali quindi la
recitazione conta relativamente
il problema è che non essendoci una vera
e propria trama decente ma questo me lo
spiegherò più avanti perché fa schifo la
trama le parti parlate di un film di
arti marziali
di solito sono normali cioè non leca di
body soul i combattimenti
qui tra un combattimento e l'altro non
vi dico la fatica per passare le parti
parlate
non solo perché i dialoghi sono
veramente orribili
gran bene c'è più
appunto ma perché sono recitati talmente
male che ti invogliano al suicidio
nome
che io sono come gli altri recensori io
non ti intero un suicidio non di nuovo
numero 3 i combattimenti e se anche i
combattimenti in un film di arti
marziali fanno schifo
potete capire anche voi quanto putrido
sia però c'è da dire che non è che siano
proprio brutti nel senso le coreografie
non sono male il problema e come sono
stati diretti perché se tu sei fare
coreografie di arti marziali non è
implicito che tu sappia anche dirigerle
potete vedere anche voi rallentamenti
colpi senza senso velocizzazione a caso
dialoghi prima e dopo dei combattimenti
che non hanno senso di esistere e
soprattutto rallentamenti cioè il
rallenty lo metti quando devi esaltare
una scena o nei film di arti marziali
quando deve esaltare la potenza di un
pugno
no qui le mettiamo completamente a caso
quindi se i dialoghi non si salvavano i
combattimenti sono fastidiosi per quanto
canini perché ricordo che non sono
brutti sono irritanti e come ogni film
di arti marziali squallido che si
rispetti ci sono gli allenamenti gli
allenamenti che non so mai allenamenti
sono katana potete vederlo solo
coreografie al vento completamente a
casa di scommesse dalla storia ma sapete
qual è il problema più grande dei
combattimenti è che sono tutti
tutti tranne l'ultimo sono tutti inutili
nel senso che ci sono i protagonisti che
devono andare a sconfiggere il cattivo e
la storia si prepara in base a quell'ora
alle decisioni che prendono i
protagonisti come in qualsiasi film loro
dicono dobbiamo investigare andiamo
investigare arriveranno magari gli
scagnozzi del nemico o qualcun altro che
bloccherà la strada per un motivo valido
per la trama loro lotteranno e
lotteranno noteranno finché non
arriveranno al nemico
no per esempio il nemico uccide tutte
quelle che assomigliano alla moglie ma
non essendo mai la moglie vera e propria
lo uccide persone sbagliate ma questo
può ancora ancora passare perché lui lo
psicopatico i protagonisti invece no
perché loro combattono investigando gli
omicidi di del cattivo e voglio a me che
loro seguono una pista e di sbagliata e
finiscono a combattere seguono un'altra
pista è sbagliata e finiscono a
combattere se un'altra pista ed è
sbagliata e finiscono a combatti centro
di combattimenti sono casuali e
completamente inutili ai fini della
trama gialla tranese è inutile se anche
i combattimenti sono inutili al fine
della trave inutile diventa un film
inutile al quadrato e voi immaginate
vigne testicoli dopo la visione del film
numero due satana in questo film ci sono
i buoni e c'è il cattivo
io non ho mai visto un cattivo così
cattivo in un film
lasciatemi raccontare la sua storia noi
all'inizio di film e viene lasciato
dalla moglie
e siccome lui ha un complesso strano che
vede la moglie come la propria mamma che
ormai ha perso da tanto tempo diventa
uno psicopatico ed inizia ad uccide a
cercare uccidere tutte le persone che
assomigliano sua moglie barra mamma cosa
non siete ancora convinti che sia satana
guardate in questa scena il cattivo vede
una donna in compagnia del suo fidanzato
che assomiglia molto a sua moglie allora
per attirare la loro attenzione lui gli
tira del ghiaccio addosso aiutatemi a
trovare il senso di questa cosa ma
comunque attira l'attenzione del marito
iniziasse a cagnano di botte ancora non
siete convinti
guardate dopo averlo scagliato di botte
gli epica due dita negli occhi e glieli
strappa via sestese vi faccio vedere la
scena rallentatore si vedono proprio i
due occhi che vengono spiaccicati a
terra ma non è finita dopo avergli
strappato gli occhi di dio in calce non
butta giù dal parcheggio e il signore
delle tenebre ma non è ancora finita
secondo voi cosa farà con la ragazza che
assomiglia alla moglie la ucciderà
troppo facile la lega e la frusta con
delle catene d'acciaio sarà e questa è
la prima ragazza che incontra poi li
incontra altri due o tre un animale è un
completo psicopatico che conosce le arti
marziali siamo fottuti
numero uno il combattimento finale è
come al solito lascia il primo posto il
meglio dei films quali il combattimento
finale secondo me l'avete visto perché
gira su youtube da parecchio tempo e ha
un sacco di visualizzazioni sotto il
nome di il miglior combattimento mai
fatto il combattimento tecnicamente
uguale a quelli prima quindi belle
coreografie ma abbastanza irritante ma
questa volta ci sono delle cose ma vi
giuro double driver per esempio
all'inizio poco prima di lottare
seriamente si tolgono i vestiti ma
guardo che come lo fanno
a
c'è ma non è che chi fa arti marziali
urla per qualsiasi cosa
pronto il ridicolo fino all'inverosimile
poi come al solito ci sono i rallenti
completamente a caso nel combattimento
ma guardate qui come sono fatti
può di certo punto arriva la
protagonista che nei combattimenti prima
si era fatta male al braccio e alla
spalla quindi alla spalla bloccata il
braccio ingessato ma il coreografo dei
combattimenti ne terrà conto
adoro i film squallidi una cosa che mi
ha stupito molto dell'ultimo
combattimento e la violenza con cui
muore il cattivo di turno
ad un certo punto dopo che è stato
picchiato per bene viene spinto contro
il muro e si infilza un occhio da un
chiodo sporgente house come se non
bastasse dopo il protagonista scriva un
colpo e il cattivo si pianta l'ultimo
occhio che gli era rimasto in un gancio
doppio out
e come se non bastasse viene attivato il
gancio e il cattivo viene trasportato
dal suo occhio o in un posto migliore
oh mio dio ho appena scoperto la mia
nuova divinità del cinema con frey o non
poteva fare un film squallido migliore
di questo se ne avete la possibilità
guardatelo insieme a degli amici perché
vi farete sicuramente un sacco di risate
mi dicono gli ultimi due aggiornamenti e
con giuro che me ne vado
se ancora non lo sapete io un secondo
canale e fra un po arriverà il video per
il concorso dei 30 mila iscritti sì
perché siete arrivati a 30 milano ora
non ci credo e volevo dirvi anche che da
questa recensione in poi metterò un link
di download per le recensioni stesse
perché un sacco di gente mi ha chiesto
se potevano scaricarsi le per mettere
sul computer e è perché no sono mie sono
vostre non siamo siamo una famiglia
ormai quindi io vi metto il link di
megaupload è un sito gratuito in cui
potete scaricare gratuitamente la
recensione i link così almeno non dovete
scaricarla da youtube che poi perde
qualità eccetera il velame mi metto il
link da te mi sono un po di tempo
permettono quindi se guardate la
decisione link ancora non c'è aspettate
un po tornate il link ci sarà